starting off this hour is Bill in
Chicago hey Bill welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey Dave how you done better
than I deserve sir Merry Christmas how
can I help
merry Christmas to you um Dave basically
our situation is uh pretty much like a
lot of your callers uh what had happened
about a year ago I lost my job a little
more than about a year and a half and we
find ourselves upside down what we had
to do is basically use credit cards to
pay off our bills and stuff like that so
now the ends are not making the means is
basically is what I'm trying to say I've
ever get a job yes sir I did
what do you make uh uh it's great to be
back at work yeah what do you make uh
basically with both of us together we're
about a hundred thousand okay what were
you making before you lost your job um
pretty much the same okay so we're back
to even there but we dug a hole in the
meantime yes sir okay so how much of a
hole did you dig uh we're about $40,000
in depth and that's all credit cards
basically yes sir
how much do in your car uh we do not
have any uh bills on either one of our
cars but they're both at the end of the
ropes so that's kind of a issue too okay
and how much is your house payment our
house payment is about $2,200 a month
are you current uh yes sir we are okay
are you current with the credit cards um
as far as we have not defaulted on
anything else you've been paid you're
not behind on your payment's no sir
okay all right you are any of the forty
thousand anything other than credit
cards what else could it be um student
loan you just uh no it's just basically
our credit cards our mortgage that we
had a second mortgage that we had taken
out I see and how much is the second
mortgage I believe that is for twenty
two thousand how much is your first
mortgage our first mortgage was for I
think we all approximately about
I'm guessing here about 220,000 okay so
like 242 is what's owed what's the house
worth ah right now I weird ass upside
down - it's not worth what it sold
anymore roughly what's it worth uh they
said it's about worth about actually you
know I should said 340 on the house
mortgage they said it's about worth
about 120 now about what about 220 220
and you owe 340 not to four you think
yes yes okay all right so you'd like a
hundred thousand bucks on 80,000 bucks
upside down there yes sir okay um and
who said the house was worth 220 well
the last time that we tried to get it
appraised we did go for that harp bill
when it came out and we did when was
that the very first year that had
happened I'm not sure what year so I
think that's about two years now
okay so the house is not the house is no
longer worth 220 it's worth a lot more
than that when you live in the
Chicagoland market it's it's recovered a
lot of that value so that's nice it's
closer to 300 probably now okay I mean
you got you active unit to get with a
realtor and find out what the house is
really worth yes well they basically
what they had told us I might be a
little wrong with my numbers Dave but
basically they still told us that were
upside-down who are the realtor when
when was that uh we tried to do this
about six months ago again okay cuz they
said well once you did the harp you can
only do a once said well we kind of
jumped on it too early the interest rate
went down more and we tried to see if we
can reinvest and they said well that
were now eligible there you get you get
one time on that that one was like yeah
just looking to try to figure out how
far upside-down you are but you're
nowhere near what you were so that's
good so we got $40,000 in credit card
debt a twenty two hundred dollar house
payment make a hundred thousand dollars
a year and you got a mess to clean up
from the year of unemployment is what it
amounts to you can do that okay how do
we do that well I mean you're going to
get on a written budget a type a tight
budget you're not gonna be going on
vacation you're not going to be going
out to eat gonna be acting like you make
100 grand you're going to be a [ __ ] you
make a lot less than that but if you pay
twenty thousand dollars a year and you
live on 80 thousand that's no big deal
that's exactly in two years yeah I mean
we don't go out we try to stay at the
strictest budget but like I said we're
still trying to you're not doing it in
writing well yeah maybe exactly yeah
exactly you're not doing a strict budget
you just have an idea that you think
you're living tight you have to do a
written plan to make your money behave
every dollar has to have a mission every
dollar has to have a name and assignment
every month and you and your spouse have
to be on in agreement on it when you do
that you'll feel not only organized and
solid but you'll feel like you got a
raise because you have money in this
situation then it feels like to you you
have right now part of that feeling is
the disorganization and part of that
feeling is you've had a year of Hell
where you got your teeth kicked in yes
and it takes a little emotionally
recover from that absolutely now do you
believe in consolidation at all David I
don't think it's everything serves any
purpose the big deal here is to get your
money working towards paying off debt
and if you pay off twenty thousand
dollars a year for two years you're done
yeah
you're dead free and now City
wellmy is it's doable it's very very
doable people do it all the time I'll
help you I'll send you a copy of our
book the Total Money Makeover which will
outline the steps exactly what you'll do
and if you'll follow that book Millions
that's a literal truth that's not an
exaggeration we've sold five million of
those books millions of people have used
those steps to get out of debt and so
hold on and Kelly I'll pick up and we'll
give you a copy of that is our gift